you
what is it life what makes it different
from just matter
everything living or not is just
chemicals made from atoms these fish and
the water the fishery in are just soups
of atoms but what makes the fish alive
and not the water is how the atoms are
organized by a special kind of molecule
and you know this because you learned
about it in high school
DNA the double helix molecule that
houses the chemical alphabet of A's and
C's and T's and G's which in different
combinations can make a flower or a frog
for you every living creature has its
code that makes it grow reproduce and
change DNA turns dust into life and how
it does that our now here's the mystery
20 years ago scientists learned to read
a creatures entire DNA sequence
beginning to end a genome it's called
they did this for simple things like
bacteria and then for more complex flies
and eventually for humans and then they
began to tinker to take the glow from a
jellyfish and transfer it to account to
make critters do what they'd never done
before and as biologists got better at
this as Stanford professor drew endy a
new kind of science was born called
synthetic biology it's a means to an end
what can we do with the new tools of
synthetic biology well we can improve on
what's been spelled out over three
billion years of evolution
we can take it beyond reading genomes or
editing genomes and start writing
genomes our own ideas of what life
should be like making creatures
drastically different from any that have
ever existed how do you do that well
already one group of scientists have
rewritten and rebuilt the entire
instruction kit for the very humble
little yeast and they plan to put their
new recipe into Excel and if everything
goes according to plan it will come
alive and begin making baby yeast
exactly like it's most unusual parent it
will be new in the world
this synthetic yeast will break the
continuous chain of evolution that links
every creature back to the first living
cell it will be discontinuous in a way a
thing unto itself and then where do we
take this new technology how far should
we or will we go